you look sharp you look good you look
like you're taking care of business I am
taking care of business yeah yeah
there's a lot my father used to say that
a lot I get dressed goes you're looking
really smart that's a smart shirt yeah
you know you're looking really smart but
also you look like yeah you look healthy
you look like you're taking care of
yourself yeah you ever hear that Andy I
don't think so in fact I do okay I stand
corrected I stand corrected well first
of all let me um let me go back and
thank you for that nice compliment
because compliments from you are very
rare and I will take that one I don't
think that's true I think I'm quite
generous with a compliment but yeah well
here let me um let me just okay because
I don't believe any of that but let me
just address what you had said yeah yeah
I'm a vegetarian you know mostly yeah on
occasion I will have fish but I'm one of
those people it's got to be a specific
fish it's got to be salmon mm-hmm right
it has to be wild salmon Wow and it has
to be caught in the big river in Montana
and it has to be bear caught a bear has
to catch it that's what I said yeah yeah
it's got to be bear caught and in his
mouth not with a fishing pole just done
then
wait let me finish oh there's more it's
I call it bear to table fish all right
very nice I like that you're looking
after yourself I care about you I care
about you too and by the way you're
looking fantastic this is your crowd
tonight yes yeah yeah finally yeah so
here's the thing you got a minute
sure I got a minute I am I asked my
friend Carl Reiner he's 96 yes i synchro
runner yeah okay
I said Carl he's just less impressed
with our wheel yeah so I asked Carl I
said what's it like being 96 he goes you
got to stay away from salt I said oh I
can't do that I love you know me and my
popcorn I got it my popcorns you're
you're famous for it I am people call me
Paul Newman sometimes has never happened
once
here's it here's the question have you
ever been that somebody's house eating
popcorn and start wondering if their
popcorn bowl was also the throw-up bowl
no who has a dedicated throw-up bowl
it is in our house and one of the week
every other week I remember that yeah
but you know what I think if you kind of
stay away from certain foods and take
care of yourself oh I read this do you
read
I read I read sucker just watch it
unfold any for a long time I didn't let
back and let out those dick lessons are
really paying
[Applause]
we love you too yeah I read that and the
average length in a span of life for
male and Hong Kong is eighty three point
six years of age eighty three point six
and in the u.s. it's 76 for male so
here's my plan
two days short of my 76 birthday moving
to Hong